hi i'm reza aslan and i'm rayne wilson
and i am a good person
pretty sure of yourself there well i
mean i'm trying to be a good person
that counts does it let's find out
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird
and we search for the meaning of life
along the way presented by cast media
and soul pancake
so rain uh you and i you know are united
in this fundamental question that keeps
us up at night which is how do we be
good people in the world how does some
how do you even how do you even start
i mean okay don't lie don't cheat don't
hurt people that's easy
yep but like how do you actively be good
in the world
i sure as hell don't know i mean we're
all so
complicated everything is on shades of
gray we're so
flawed like can you really be good
every time i'm good or i think oh that
was good
then i in my head i kind of pat myself
on the back or i kind of go i wonder if
people are witnessing me being good
and then it immediately makes it bad it
doesn't count anymore
boom like have i done selfless acts
you know without any thought of
recognition reward
or praise uh i don't know i don't know
that i have
i get it yeah or i mean
you know just to sort of like be hip and
be
with it as a progressive liberal the
very idea that
there is an absolute good you know
i'm a little uncomfortable with like i i
think there is like
if you were to ask me like is there
absolute good and absolute evil yeah
yeah
there is but then then you're talking
about defining what good is because as
good as
is good something that we define
culturally um is it something that we
have
instinctually a lot of people say we
have a
you know an instinct for good it's in
our dna it's in the wiring of our brains
we have an impulse toward good that
doesn't come from any divine source
then a lot of people would argue well
good comes from god
you know they're the same word good god
and um
uh that morality you know the ten
commandments let's say those are
god-given and we should follow them
because they come from our
creator as opposed to this just makes
the most sense for a society so how do
you
how do you shift between those things
you know what would help actually
what somebody should invent some kind of
app or whatever that just sort of gives
you
points every time you do something good
right and takes away points every time
you do something bad
that's an amazing idea and someone
should document that in a documentary
television show
something about that feels familiar what
is it what is it
oh right one of my favorite shows on
television
the good place a good place with our
good
friend mike shore the uh creator of
the good place i worked with him on the
office that must have been fun he's
amazing he is so funny
and very generous big-hearted uh big
ideas
he was an executive producer in the
office then he co-created parks and
recreation
and brooklyn nine-nine and now he's
wrapping up the final season of said
show the good place
and that the reason we wanted to bring
him here is that one of the things about
the good place is that it really tackles
with this issue of moral philosophy what
does it mean to be good what does it
mean to be bad it does it in a 30 minute
sitcom format so it's it's fantastic
that he's managed to even
uh put this out there you know in in the
in the public space and have people
enjoy it but there's something very
serious underneath this which is
very much this notion of in a
complicated complex
weirdly interconnected world
can any action truly be
good or bad yeah it's uh
is i can't i can't even wrap my head
around it so maybe mike can help us
wrap our heads around this but you know
you were in trouble when we bring in a
hollywood writer to help explain the
world to us
you know this we need a latte sipping
tesla driving arrogant uh
elitist to come in and show us the way
unfortunately we have one
hey mike shore everybody
[Music]
i i'm an extreme rule follower and have
always been an extreme rule follower and
i this is not a joke i was the kid who
at
uh in college there was like a noise
ordinance or whatever that was like you
have to you know parties have to end at
midnight
and if i was at a party at like 1205 if
the music was still really loud i would
quietly go over and like
turn it down yeah even if it wasn't my
room because i was like we're going to
get in trouble we're breaking the rule
and
so you can imagine that was a lot of fun
in college but
i i just was like if there's a rule then
you should follow the rule that
has always been the way where did that
come from is it were you did you come
from a religious background
no no not at all religious i i went to a
unitarian church occasionally and when i
was growing up
fake fake religion fake religion or like
oh like
let's hang out religiously let's just
hang out and talk about stuff
um but i it was just the my sort of
internal
compass setting was was that was like
follow rules like
i i my wife makes fun of me a lot
because
i rinse my mouth with mouthwash every
night and i do it for 30 seconds
which is a really long time because on
the label it says use for 30 seconds
that's fantastic yeah and like i was
like well they you know
so that's just that's always been the
kind of person i have been
is a extreme rule follower so as i've
gone through life
i am very upset when people don't
follow rules when people feel like these
rules don't apply to me i'm special
i don't have to do this i i can do the i
can cut the line
i can cut a corner i can uh i don't have
to obey
the rules that we as a society have
established
and so i was driving in my car on the
101
and a guy pulled out into the breakdown
lane
and just whizzed past everybody and
i did a thing um that i have done a lot
in my life which is
i imagine that someone's keeping score
and
that guy just lost 20 points like it was
a point in my head it was a point system
like that guy just lost 20 points and
then on this one occasion
um parks and recreation if it's only 20
points you lose from doing that i'm
gonna do that
every day totally worth it so worth it
but you have to think like in my point
system you have to think like okay
you know uh murder is a million or
something right
there's there's a scale here right it's
like it's not he's not murdering anyone
he has just decided this guy has just
decided like yes i know everyone else
has to sit here in traffic yeah but i
don't because i'm scared
yeah so parks and rec was winding down
on this particular occasion
when i did this thing i had done a
number of times before and then i
suddenly was like well wait a second
maybe there is an actual big idea there
that that that
is the way that it happens that someone
is just keeping score it's just math
it's moneyball
it's not religious it's not there's no
uh
deity it's just a system that determines
the point value of moral actions of
ethical decisions
and maybe that is a show and maybe and
then
very quickly things sort of tumbled on
top of each other then it was like
okay only the top five percent get in
because it's a really elitist
system and then maybe someone gets in
who shouldn't be there
and then it just sort of it it just kind
of it it all kind of unfolded in a way
fantastic and i think it i think it
unfolded as quickly as it did for me
because i had been thinking that way my
whole life like okay so that guy
that guy who went down the shoulder of
the road he got 5 000 points because he
gave you that idea
well someone i was i was speaking with
will harper who plays chidi
uh at an event in boston at wbur
recently and someone asked me a question
i've never gotten before which was
do you think that coming up with this
system
that is very judgy and is basically
saying like i
like i have i have uh identified like a
system of
judging other people for their moral
decisions do you think that that action
has cost you points in your life
like you think that you're you're going
to be punished for this and i was like
oh my god i've never thought of it
what was your answer what do you think i
sort of gasped
you're screwed yeah well you know what's
interesting about this is that
there is a long history behind it um
the the very concept of a heaven and
hell is actually kind of a new
idea it's barely about 3 000 years old
right so you know
before then it was basically like if you
died you would just go on to the next
life and you would continue to be
whatever you were in this life like
morality had nothing
to to do with it and then uh the first
the first person that we know uh in
recorded history who kind of came up
with this idea that no no
the moral actions that you do on this
life actually
uh dictate what happens to you in the
next life
um was the persian prophet zarathustra
and he had something similar
he he had a like a threefold formula
it was good words good thoughts good
deeds
versus bad words bad thoughts bad deeds
and he literally
thought that it was a scale that like at
the end you show up and there's this
there's god and he's got a scale and he
puts all your good words thoughts and
actions on one side
your bad words thoughts and actions on
the other and it just
wherever it tipped that's what happened
you either went to heaven or you went to
hell
so this this is an old idea it's it's
it's
an ancient idea yeah yeah uh michael the
character ted danson plays is named
michael because my wife and i
for our 10-year anniversary went to
paris and we were looking at notre dame
and there's stonework at the top of the
main entrance at notre dame and the
stonework
just shows the archangel michael who was
in charge in the catholic religion of
weighing people's souls in
a similar fashion and to his right
the uh the sinners are slowly descending
to hell into his left they're slowly
rising up to heaven
and i hadn't figured out what the
character's name would be
uh until i saw that and i was like oh
that's his name should be michael
and because of that faithful decision uh
everyone has assumed that i named the
character after myself
and it's been very hard to convince
people you are the judge
yeah but there's a wonderful book i read
a lot of books uh
over the course of the show in
preparation to write it and then while
writing it and
megan amram who is one of the writers on
the show said there's this great book we
gotta read it's
it's called the penguin book of hell and
it's just a it's a number of ancient
sort of um descriptions of how how
ancient prophets ancient thinkers
described what they thought hell wasn't
and uh it's really wonderful and it's
sort of in bite-sized nuggets there's
little introductions that explain it and
then you get the actual text
and i think it's socrates had this
wonderful vision of it where
when you die you basically are like
drowning in a river for like a year
and you're forced to think about all of
the things that you've done
and all of the people you've hurt in
your life and all of the bad actions
that you've done
and you basically pop up after a year
and
you have to beg for forgiveness from the
people you've hurt
and they get to decide like are you
sincere
if they don't you go back and they don't
back into the river there you go and you
got to think for another year
wow so yes in the ancient world there
are dozens and dozens of different
sort of variations on a theme about what
it means to have done bad things and
then to how to
how to sort of get out of them how to
free how to like come to a place of
forgiveness
either from god or from your fellow
humans
and um it was like the best thing about
making this show for the last
five years now has been reading all of
that stuff yeah it's just
endlessly fascinating to me and you're
the first tv show that has
a philosophy professor on staff and this
is fascinating that
you started when you were starting the
show preparing the show you spoke to
pamela hieronomy yeah um uh about ethics
and morality you had a conversation that
lasted for
for three hours this was about uh
intention and motivation and how that
colors are moral behavior
yeah and um so tell me about that
initial conversation and what professor
heuronomy
brings to the show i sat down with her
and i explained the idea of the show
and i said it's basically about a bunch
of people who weren't really great
people on earth for a variety of
different reasons
but they get to this place and then they
their mission is to try to become good
people
and she said well that's impossible and
i said why and she said well because
most great
moral philosophers would tell you that
you can't try to be good it's impossible
uh and i said well that's a very bad
news for me
because i've made a very large bet in my
professional life that it is possible
uh and i said did anyone no okay can we
slow down a little bit
how can you not try to be good i i've
experienced this in my life where it's
like
i've been a jackass for an extended
period of time i know
and then i yeah right you experience it
yeah and then
a little taste um and then i've tried to
be a better person and try to be less of
a jackass
you know folks part of the reason why
reyna and i do this podcast metaphysical
milkshake is because
we love to think we love to learn
and you know there's like so many
streaming services
right now that are available whose
entire purpose is to quote
turn your brains off you know like
mindless entertainment
stuff like that but thankfully there's
one dream we love wandrum it's the
streaming service that
absolutely blows our minds one dream has
thousands of audio and video learning
experiences to feed our curiosity
one dream's content is fun and exciting
and gives us access to a world of
knowledge from
top experts and storytellers with
documentaries tutorials
and collections from kina lorber
magellan tv and craftsy
there's so many cool programs to check
out reza tell them what you can find on
one dream well it's like being back in
school again remember how fun it was to
be back in school and to learn stuff
all the time uh there are so many cool
programs
on wanderium to check out like there's
think like a stoic
that's a great one they've got uh great
revolutions of modern history i mean
there have been so many revolutions it's
hard to keep up with the revolutions
russian revolution french iranian you
know something about that
i lived through that one but i learned
so much that i didn't know it is
absolutely a must watch so join us and
experience your own
mind-blowing moments with one tree right
now our listeners can get this special
offer a free trial
of unlimited access to the entire
library
wow that's huge so go now to
onedrive.com
milkshake to sign up that's
w-o-n-d-r-i-u-m
dot com slash milkshake one dream dot
com
slash milkshake keep learning folks monk
back monk pack
brought to you by monk pack healthy
snacks have a bad reputation
and for a very good reason because most
of them taste like crap
so this episode of metaphysical
milkshake
is sponsored by monk pack
who makes snacks that taste like our
favorite sugary treats
but with one gram of sugar or less
they're great for anyone following a
keto
lifestyle but also the perfect snack for
anyone who's trying to eat better
they sent me two giant boxes i got one
medium box
what is up with that i think they know
that i have a gigantic family and by the
way it was good because it was like
wolves just like tearing into the box
everybody got their favorite flavors
mine was the coconut cocoa one and
there's peanut butter blueberry almond
vanilla
i'm telling you i'm obsessed with these
bars basically i don't eat lunch anymore
i just grab a monk pack instead
we have a special deal for our listeners
get 20 off
your first purchase of any monk pack
product
by visiting monkpack.com and entering
our code
guess what our code is reza i'm going to
guess it has something to do with
milkshake
you got it how'd you know it is
milkshake and enter that code at
checkout
monk pack is so confident in their
product it's backed with a 100
satisfaction guarantee and if you don't
like it for any reason they'll exchange
the product or refund your money
whichever you prefer
so to get started just go to
monkpack.com
select any product then enter the code
milkshake at the checkout
you're going to save 20 off your
purchase monk pack delicious
nutritious food you can count on and we
thank them
for sponsoring this podcast
well this is it's a little bit uh
misleading to say
when when we say you can't try to be
good what it means to you and me is
different from what it means to a moral
philosopher
the way that she explained it to me was
i could say to you
rain um i will give you a million
dollars
if you believe that um
zendaya is the president of the united
states if you can believe that i will
give you a million dollars and you can
try
really hard you can wake up every day
and say sendai is the president and you
can like
make leaflet to say re-elect zendaya
2020 or whatever
but you will never actually believe it
because you know
internally that it's not the truth and
so
trying to become good is like if you're
not a good person
trying to become good is just you're
getting asymptotically closer
to being good but you'll never actually
be good that's the sort of explanation
that she gave me and i said
well okay is there anyone who
who ever believed that you can try to be
good and she said well
sort of aristotle and i was like great
that's my guy
that's not going with that i got one guy
okay so
she talked to me very graciously for
three hours and she led me through she
assigned me reading basically i said
like what do i need to read
she was a disciple of a philosopher
named tim scanlon who
is a emeritus professor at harvard and
he wrote a book called what we owe to
each other that has become really really
important for
the show and basically he said if you're
stu he's sort of a
a colleague and disciple of john rawls
who's sort of the great sort of social
contract theorist of the last
infinite amount of time and what scanlon
said was
the way that you establish your rules in
a society if you have to establish rules
is you have everyone sits around a table
and everybody has a veto anyone can veto
any rule
and you propose a rule and if any
reasonable person sitting at the table
can't reject your rule then that means
it's a good rule so it's basically a set
it's like setting a bare minimum
of what everybody that you need to agree
to rules with
can't reasonably reject and it's a
really lovely idea it's very simple idea
the book is not simple the book is very
complicated
but the central idea was we all have to
get along we all have to share this
little
spot of earth that we're that we're
sharing and so the way to determine how
to share it and how to set up rules
is if you is if no one else you pitch a
rule and no one says
yeah that rule stinks so if i said if we
were sitting around a room and i said
you know i think people named mike
should get more money than people named
rain you would very reasonably say well
that's not fair i think you want some
people would be like there's nobody
named ray what kind of
stupid name is that everyone's gonna be
telling me he owns a zonkey
everyone else would agree to it because
they would say like who cares if people
named rain get screwed
um i read a distillation actually of
that book and was like okay this woman
is right on the money in terms of the
kinds of stuff we're talking about
on this show and i basically said can we
sort of put you on retainer
and when we need help we'll call you and
so she's come in
and i did this with another guy named
todd may who teaches at clemson
and um and when we were stuck or we just
wanted to like
investigate something we would call them
and they would either come in pam came
in and taught us the trolley problem
which was really fun
would you turn into a whole episode
that's if you would throw someone off a
train or something yeah the trolley
problem is sort of the most famous
philosophical thought experiment it was
invented by a woman named philip a foot
in the mid 60s it was a british
philosopher and the basic formulation is
if you don't know is um you're on a
trolley and the brakes fail
and the trolley's going to run over five
people and kill them
and there's a lever that you can pull
that will switch tracks
and go on to another track and there it
will kill one person
what do you do and most people say well
it's better that one only one person
dies than if five people die
so yeah i'd pull the lever and then
there's infinite variation she says what
if you're the driver of the trolley
and you're contracted to this is your
job does that change the calculation
what if you know one of the people does
that change the calculation what if
you are a surgeon and there is a
uh a man who's gonna die uh unless he
gets
uh there's five people sorry who are
gonna die unless they get organ
transplants one of them needs a liver
one of them needs a heart one of them
needs
two kidneys whatever and and they're all
gonna die
and outside there's a janitor who's
perfectly healthy minding his business
sweeping up is it permissible to kill
him
and harvest his organs and then put the
liver in the one guy who needs a liver
and the heart and the just goes on and
on
right and and the fun of it what if the
five people were senior citizens
and the one person was a toddler exactly
and so the fun of the trolley problem
isn't that there's an answer the fun of
it is to show you
that your sort of moral calculations are
fluid that when you say yes it's
permissible to pull the lever and kill
that one guy
you are inconsistent because later
you'll say well no it's not permissible
to kill that janitor that's insane
but it's still killing one person to
save five people and so it's
it's a wonderful thought experiment it's
become this kind of
litmus test for people to figure out
where their
moral sense is and how it shifts and
changes given different
sort of calculations and stuff um the
trolley problem
actually gets to the central theme of
the
show and so much of what we've been
talking about which is
are there moral absolutes or is
everything in
flux and the the
sort of the theology of the show right
the idea of the good place is that no
there are more absolutes everything
literally has
a score to it and it's just math and
it's either right or it's wrong
and there is no gray area right um
you're either good or you're not good um
and of course the the conflict is
in trying to challenge that with you
know these four
characters who are not that great and
who are trying to be better and
you know is there some gray area where
do you land as a as a person because i
mean it seems you were
describing how you were always a rule uh
keeper yeah which makes me think okay
well then you're you must be some kind
of
you know moral yes yeah some kantian uh
dude um obviously you've injected so
much life into these characters who
represent the opposite
yeah um where do you land well
i ironically um i land very far away
from rule following
in terms of my own personal feelings
about about morality
the the rule followers are the kantians
or the deontological
followers who was who say basically
every situation there's a rule
you got to figure out what the rule is
and then you follow the rule end of
story kant is so intense about this
stuff
he he kant believes um someone's trying
to kill your brother
and um your brother runs your house and
says you gotta hide me
uh because this guy's trying to kill me
then the killer comes to your door
and says uh where's your brother i'm
trying to kill him
kant says you're not allowed to lie to
that guy lying is so bad
for him that you're not allowed to say i
have no idea where he is now you are
allowed to say
on a technicality ah jeez you know
yesterday i saw him down the street at
the grocery store
maybe i don't know maybe check there
you're allowed to cut you're allowed to
say
things that are not true but aren't lies
or at least
aren't the full truth right um
people who love kant really love kant
people are
super super into him because i can't
stand him
classic he's uh he's promising you
something very
tantalizing he is promising you that you
can figure out the answer
whatever the situation is there's an
answer you
you figure out what the what the rule is
and you follow the rule that's a very
appealing idea i also think it's kind of
absurd
so i'm out on on them right i'm out on
the you're not a con i'm not a continent
another people like what brother i don't
even have a brother yeah like
yeah exactly i would say you've got the
wrong house buddy
um another school of thought is the
consequentialists right who are like it
doesn't matter
the only thing that matters is the
results like the the right action is the
one that leads to the best results so
the most pleasure or happiness and the
least pain and suffering
and utilitarianism utilitarianism yes
and so you do whatever the thing is that
gives you the best results the problem
with that is
you get into these really dicey
situations where it's like okay what if
you could torture one innocent person to
save the lives of
a hundred or 500 or a million other
people
well that doesn't seem like a good
system right if innocent people could be
it's sort of like the lottery that
shirley jackson story or whatever
and the way that the consequentialists
answer that
question is well you're you're not
calculating right you're not calculating
the amount of pleasure happiness and
sadness correctly because
if you had to live in a society where
you knew that at any moment you could be
tortured as an innocent person
in order to save the lives of others you
would live in fear and
misery all the time i don't know i buy
that i don't think i buy that argument
and so i end up personally being more in
the aristotle world
aristotle's thing was loosely called
virtue ethics
and basically what he says is look there
are certain virtues we all agree are
good things
right uh kindness and generosity honesty
honesty
and humility whatever so the goal is to
just practice
those things uh as well as you can and
and he does literally think of it as
practice he thinks of it like playing
the flute
or something like the more you play the
flute the better you get the more you
practice
honesty and courage that's what i'm
talking about trying to be good yes
you can develop these qualities and many
spiritual traditions would say these are
qualities of the divine
right and that they these are the
qualities we're trying to
inspire and still grow within us and
honestly i don't
know that it matters whether whence
comes the those virtues personally i
think if you
if you if you think of them as things
that have been divinely given
in whatever faith you follow great or if
it's just common
societal comments i like it when other
people are right
yes and and so aristotle says uh
look kurt let's take courage right
courage is generally thought of as a
good virtue
if you have the if you don't have enough
courage and you go into battle you'll
shrink in fear and run away and desert
your
army and your friends if you have too
much courage you'll say
uh let me add them and you'll charge
over the hill by yourself and you'll get
slaughtered so somewhere in the middle
is the exact median the exact right
amount of courage and so that's what
he's
striving at and what he wants us to
strive at is the exact right amount of
all of these virtues
and the practice is testing it's trial
and error and you try
x thing and you try y thing and
eventually you sort of hone in
on what the right amount of all these
virtues is and that's sort of where i
end up i think if
if i'm particular to any of these major
schools of thought that's the one that i
think i'm closest to
hey rayne have you ever had one of those
ideas that you just don't know how to
get started on making into a reality
so many reza so many a rock opera about
my life
an electric pogo stick if you've been
procrastinating on any of those
genius ideas guess what you're not alone
experts say that not knowing
how or where to start is one of the
biggest causes of procrastination okay
so why are we talking about
procrastination because
we're here to promote the blinkist app
blinkist b-l-i-n-k-i-s-t
takes non-fiction books pulls out the
key takeaways
and puts them into text and audio
explainers called blinks
that you can learn from in just 15
minutes you can use blinks to learn
about how to tackle
procrastination you see they have
blinked
thousands of titles in like 27
categories
and they're all ready to learn in just
15 minutes you can learn while you're
washing dishes or working out which
i do all the time obviously or if you're
winding down and hanging out on the
couch which i never do
listen our time is limited you're not
able to necessarily read
every single book that comes out but you
want them distilled right
books that people are talking about like
hillbilly elegy
or how to be an anti-racist people are
talking about these books all the time
maybe you don't have time to read them
you probably should read them but if you
can't get the blink version
of these best-selling titles here's the
best part right now blinkist has a
special offer
just for our audience no one else gets
this folks
go to blinkist.com milkshake you can
start your
free seven-day trial and you can also
get 25
off of blinkist premium membership
that's blinkist
and it's spelled b l i n k
i s t blinkist dot com
slash milkshake 25 off and a seven day
free trial
blinkist.com milkshake what are you
waiting for
[Music]
good versus evil is dealt with a lot in
your show
not necessarily in a religious context
but
one of the kind of big moral questions
around good and evil
is you have this kind of uh
catholic tradition and even islamic
where there is a devil or a satan
there is a source of evil just as there
is a source of good
i think isn't that zoroastrian as well
that there's
you know the good god and the evil god
and there
uh and there's a constant battle between
the two of them
yeah um versus the idea that
evil is simply an absence of good so
evil being more like darkness
yeah where a light bulb is on and in the
shadowy corners evil can exist because
the light
doesn't reach there how how do you
incorporate that into
your belief system and into the belief
system of the good place
part of what the show has done is um in
over the last couple years especially
is it has basically tried to
fight against the simplicity right in
the the characters in the show
um have determined that the actual point
system that's being used on the show
is garbage and the reason it's garbage
is
in the old days a long long long time
ago you do something
nice for your friend you your friend's
birthday
and you get your friend a present you
you there's a garden outside your house
and you cut the flowers and you bring
them over to your friend you say happy
birthday well that's worth 58 points
right
in the modern world it's your friend's
birthday and you use your smartphone
to go to a website and you order the
flowers for your friend and have them
delivered
but the cell phone was made in a
sweatshop in china and the website is
owned by some international conglomerate
that is
like screwing over its employees and
you're using electricity which is
burning coal which is putting
particulates into the flowers are grown
and some the flowers are grown in
chile and they and the carbon footprint
of shipping them from
in the water used to grow them is so
what used to be 58 points or whatever
is now like you're losing seven points
because the impact of your actions in
the modern world
is enormous and and that is why in the
world of the show
we found out last year no one has
actually gotten into the good place in
500 years
and it's because there's no such thing
as simplicity anymore the world is too
connected and the
ripple effects of your actions are
essentially infinite like you
you don't do anything big or small that
doesn't affect a number of other people
and so that's been a big part of what
we've been arguing
on the show is that like that in that
that any kind of system that tries to
evaluate moral worth in the modern era
forget it man you're you're screwed
basically this is where we've ended up
if you try to be a good person no matter
how hard you try no matter how
conscientious you
you are you're going to fail because
you're going to do things that you don't
even know are bad
and you're going to think maybe you're
doing good you're going to eat a
sandwich from a restaurant and then
you're going to find out the next day
that that restaurant hates gay people
like literally every
the guy who owns the restaurant hates
gay people and so you have just given
that guy four bucks to get your chicken
sandwich right
and that's not your fault you didn't
know and it's not
reasonable to expect people in with the
complexity of the modern world
to know everything that they're doing
it's literally impossible
and so the important thing for us
ends up being that you're trying that
you are attempting that you're
conscientious that you think you're not
complacent
and that when you find out oh this uh
this fried chicken chain hates gay
people
if you don't hate gay people uh then you
shouldn't go there anymore
right like you and and the argue the
counter argument ends up being well
every place is terrible every
restaurant's terrible every company is
terrible blah blah blah
blah so you're going to fail again and
our response is
yeah you are and then you got to try
again like you got to go to a different
if you want a chicken sandwich go to
someplace else and then if you find out
that that place also hates gay people
or hates mexican people or something
don't go to that one anymore
then after all you're trying you're
making a tv show for the national
broadcasting corporation so that they
can show commercials
and they can sell more cars that pollute
the environment and
et cetera like that so you're yeah and
your show itself is part of the
is a cog in this greater system i am
failing
all the time as is everyone as a moral
agent in the universe everyone is
failing
all the time could you give us an
example of a time in your recent past
where
um you know you came to these kinds of
crossroads and it was all about trying
to be good and
maybe tell us about a time in which you
succeeded and maybe a time that you
didn't succeed
well the time i the time i think i
succeeded was
was this exact the argument i gave a
second ago of
um of chick-fil-a is the company right
the chick for the owner of chick-fil-a
is came out a while ago and made
incredibly disparaging comments about
the lgbtqia plus community
i've never eaten a chick-fil-a sandwich
in my life i'm a vegetarian and have
been for
a while now so i and and even before
that i've never eaten a chick-fil-a
sandwiches and never got around to it
then that guy comes out and says all
these stupid things about uh
the lgbtqia plus community and i was
like all right well no one should eat
there anymore and a bunch of people that
i work with and whose opinions i
greatly respect and i think of as very
progressive
smart thoughtful conscientious people
were like but it's so good
there's there's pickles you had a joke
in in the in the show yeah there's a
great joke
we put it into the show and and i i
could not believe i was having this
argument i was like guys
he's a monster that guy sucks like don't
go don't give him money
and they tried every argument they tried
well what about the employees of the
company and i was like yeah that does
hurt but like you you your vote is with
your money
like you get to vote whether or not to
support that guy go to popeyes
there you go and get a sandwich and and
and then the the next argument is
well yeah if we go to popeyes what if we
find out in a couple weeks that the guy
who
has a like a child trafficking ring or
something i was like then don't go to
popeyes anymore like this isn't
to me this isn't hard and the the idea
that you're going to
fail by doing something else and so you
should never try to do
you should never change your behavior at
all is reductive and stupid it's like
you still gotta try like just try keep
trying like keep trying to find the
right place
okay but have you had your own personal
chick-fil-a sandwich moment i mean yeah
that's
honestly kind of easy for you because
all right don't go to chick-fil-a you
don't eat meat anyway so who
gives a [ __ ] but but
i'm curious if you've had that moment
where you know whatever
the chick-fil-a sandwich is was just
it was too good you know oh like i
should i sh i'm taking the wrong path
here
i mean i'm sure i have let me try to
think offhand uh what about working in
the television industry
yeah i mean that's that's the biggest
one right i mean look i i created a
co-created a show with my friend dan
gore called brooklyn nine-nine and it
airs on
fox uh fox i don't know if you know this
is owned by rupert murdoch yeah
or at least was it's not anymore he's
the guy from success but lachlan is just
his worse
he i mean he's so just as bad i mean so
i uh
so a while ago and i i haven't
i haven't day to day work on that show
since season two really i'm still
involved in that i read scripts and i
talked to dan a lot and whatever
but like i haven't actually worked there
but it's still like i created that show
with him right
and i don't think there's a more
destructive
force in american society than fox news
i think that fox and globally murdoch
and globally murdoch sure
um at least in terms of media like i
think
fox news is is when we talk about
how striated the culture is and how
divisive the culture is never started
there
it is there's no single thing you can
point to more than
fox news fox news has turned evil it's
turned a lot of people into like
into unthinking um reactionary zombies
who believe
that um that anyone who is not a white
man
over the age of 50 is coming to murder
them and
um so i had a day-to-day week-to-week
month-to-month year to year
paying of conscious like anguish
about the fact that i was working for
that company
and and drawing money from that company
and i and
there's sort of a and then again you you
start doing the calculation right you
think like okay well that show
features a character who is an
african-american
gay man who is who's in charge in charge
and the second in charge is another
african-american man played by terry
crews the delightful terry crews
and it has two latinx uh female
detectives who are
awesome who were in two very different
ways
one of them is just a total [ __ ] kicking
awesome superhero and one of them is
like
the smartest detective at the force and
the person who is the
is the best at her job of anyone
probably and
so what is the calculation right this is
where the point system comes in like am
i doing
am i doing enough are we doing it yes
are we doing enough
to counter balance the fact that fox is
making money off of this
by putting on screen a number of people
who can serve as
representatives and role models for
people who have been traditionally
underrepresented on television
i don't know maybe it's impossible to
tell we don't have the omniscient
calculator that the show has to say like
yes this
you gain eight points for this and lose
six points for this or whatever
my brother-in-law is a pastor and um
you know he has this statement that
really hit me hard he said
basically you are what you do
if you do good or at least strive to do
good
you're good if you strive to do
evil you're evil it's not complicated
so i love this idea of just
being good or not good is less
a sort of uh philosophical
slippery problem about the nature of
humanity
and just more well what do you do right
i mean
do you go out there and you try your
best try to do good
or not and that's kind of all there is
to it yeah that is
that is it's a it's another way of
saying i think the same thing right
it's like you're you're confronted with
a
thousand decisions a day and if you just
take one second and think about well the
way i think of it is four questions
in every decision you make what am i
doing
why am i doing it is there something i
could do that's better
and what is that thing and if you just
sort of apply those basic questions to
your actions
and and then try to live that way
you're you'll become a good person or at
least a better person than you were
before and my point
ultimately the sort of umbrella point is
the important thing
is the asking of those questions i think
the danger that we fall into
in my opinion is when you stop asking
those questions complacency
yes it's complacency it's when you start
acting on autopilot and not
thinking about what you're doing and by
the way the reason it's hard to change
your behavior is because it's
embarrassing to find out you've been
doing something bad
when when you confront someone and say
hey this thing you're doing eating that
chicken sandwich
it's bad it's it's helping this guy
who's a who's a bad guy
it's embarrassing no one wants to think
of him or herself as a person who does
bad things and so we're
our we have this there's a thing called
the backfire effect that kicks in
psychologically which is when people
find out that they've been doing
something bad if it's a
especially if it's like a core value if
they get new information
they don't change their behavior and
myth they're wrong they double down
they go no it's actually good that i'm
doing this and i'm going to go back and
do it more
and like it's this is with a climate
change deniers yes exactly
confronted with the real science they
actually
and i think part of the reason is it's
embarrassing to think of yourself as a
person who does
bad things and so the the important
thing i really believe this is asking
those questions
[Music]
make sure this has been an amazing
conversation
we end each session with what we call
the lightning round and we want a
short rapid fire answer to them great
the short part it is pithy short
funny inspiring and uh thought provoking
ready go
he will be morally judged oh great by
these ants mike sure
when do you feel most connected with the
universe uh right before i go to sleep
what makes you laugh out loud rain is
pointing to himself
i'll say rain wilson's performance on
the office oh thank you
you win he is really angling describe
your soul
in ten words or less flawed but
in the process of working out its flaws
i hope that was ten fewer words
i think you did it okay what's your
biggest fear
dying before i have the chance to write
everything
and do everything that i want to do what
is one thing you hate
uh hypocrisy when was the last time you
ugly cried
um can i do can i
request permission to give a little
background
it's a known phenomenon uh amongst a lot
of people i think that you tend to cry
more when you watch movies on airplanes
yeah this phenomenon right yes
for some reason some people say it's the
thin oxygen other people say it's
because your
your body is already like a little bit
afraid all the time or whatever but it's
very common thing right
so um i watched the movie interstellar
on a plane which i'd never seen before
and for some reason i i just sobbed i
like i sobbed like i didn't even truth
be told like the movie that much
but i sobbed at the end of that movie
really hard and then i knew there was
something weird because i then watched
anchorman 2 right afterwards and also
cried at anchorman
okay yeah you were you were on something
what is one thing you know for sure
no pun intended
that given the choice between
being kind and being cruel most
people will be kind and then finally
what is your life's big
question oh man um
well i mean given the fact that i've
been writing this show for four years
i think the big question the one big
question
should be if we are judged
by anyone or anything at the end of our
lives
what is the basis of that judgment is it
our actions
or our thoughts or are we graded on a
curve based on where we were born and
who we were born to and what our life
circumstances were or is it absolute and
just
everyone who lives in a major city is
screwed
mark sure this has been one of my
absolute favorite episodes profound
conversation thank you so much for your
time thank you for having me this is
really fun
thank you
[Music]
what a fantastic conversation uh there's
so many levels
such complexity to these issues and yet
also
something so simple that is really it's
like sticking with me which is
what does it mean to be good it means
trying to be good
that's it yeah so it's intent was it
yeah just try
it's intent i intend to be good i may
fail
and i may [ __ ] up but i'm intending keep
trying keep trying
um so you know he he brought up of
course the trolley problem which is one
of my
favorite episodes uh on the show but
you know back in 2015 mcsweeney's the
great um magazine uh founded by my
friend
dave eggers yeah i'm just throwing out
names um
he ran this very funny list of lesser
trolley problems really and i thought i
would uh i would ask them to you and
give them a shot oh okay
i'll let i will dig in i love it okay i
think i got this figured out
first one yeah the time traveler there's
an out-of-control trolley speeding
towards a worker
you have the ability to pull a lever and
change the trolley's path
so it hits a different worker right okay
basic
it's just that the different worker is
actually the first worker 10 minutes
from now
um i would hit the uh
i would hit the older of the two workers
given because more minutes of life
they've well they've had their ch
they've had that extra 10 minutes
they've had that [ __ ] i like that okay
the suicide note okay out of control
trolley
this one is speeding towards a worker
you have the ability to pull a lever and
change the trolley's path
so it hits a different worker but here's
the thing the first worker has an
intended suicide note
in his back pocket but it's in the
handwriting of the second worker and the
second worker is wearing a t-shirt that
says please hit me with a trolley
but the shirt is borrowed from the first
worker
um they both want to die so i would
run i would hit the first worker jump
out of the trolley
and strangle the strangle the second one
that's exactly the right answer
okay here's one there's an
out-of-control trolley speeding towards
two workers
they're both massive dicks okay you have
the ability to pull a lever and change
the trolley's path so it just hits
one worker but he's an even bigger dick
so two massive dicks
or one gigantic dick
i would i would hit the two i would hit
the two decks
because uh overpopulation well i know
for a fact that a lot of listeners felt
very much the same way about this topic
that i did i was definitely moved by
mike shore's
idea about like what it means to be a
good person and
and a lot of you out there uh had a lot
to say about this we got a lot of
voicemails
uh why don't we start with one this is
tony i believe that you're a good person
if the amount of positive energy you put
out into the world
outweighs the amount of negative energy
that you put out into the world and i
know that sounds very
hippie-like and mystical but um
i think that's really what it boils down
to you know
do you build people up or do you knock
people down you know
if it's too hard for you to build other
people up probably not a good person
that's just my philosophy quicken to the
point my friend
very nice tony actually you know uh
this is an ancient zoroastrian concept
zoroastrians believe that you know
there's a scale
and on one side of the scale is your
good words good thoughts good deeds and
on the other side of the scale is your
bad words bad thoughts bad deeds and if
the good outweighs the bad then you're a
good
person and you get paradise and if the
bad outweighs the good then you
don't uh you know it's kind of as simple
as that yeah
i believe one thousand percent this is
my end all be all in
the golden rule that is my religion if
you could call it that
um because you can find that in every
religion do under others
as you would have them do under unto you
and and i think that
that's the end actually wow i didn't
even need 90 seconds
do you want others as you would have
them do unto you
it's it's karma you know put out what
you want to get back
and that is so absurdly important
and just in everyday life and especially
in the world that we live in right now
a golden rule great a great way to go
has been there since the dawn of time
it's in
every single religion it's actually
really fun to play a game with kids
where you find the golden rule in every
faith tradition even like native
american traditions
and you scramble them up and put them in
a hat and draw them out and try and
guess
which religion it comes from uh it's
pretty universal
and the the great writer and thinker
karen armstrong
has a recently come up with this charter
for compassion
and the golden rule is at the center of
that and it's um
it's a it's an international charter
that she wants people
of all different religious faiths to
sign on to and it
uh is to deepen ever deepen our
compassion and the golden rule is kind
of the bridge that one
walks across to get there now i will say
that
baha'is do it better
baha'is have one-upped the golden rule
you know how that is reza
what what's that for baha'is is due unto
others
better than you would have them do
oh you guys gotta one-up everybody don't
you boom behind mic drop
so suck it michaela well you know islam
has something similar too
and it's whatever you are we're better
so it's the it's almost the same thing
yeah
that's not quite how it works but thanks
for your call thanks for your questions
uh these this has been truly delightful
i think that being a good person means
to be loving and caring towards other
people
there are a lot of people that will
always be ready to tell you something
that you're doing wrong
and you know kind of there there's
always going to be people that are ready
to belittle
you but it's people that
are kind to each other and that show
respect for one another
that makes a difference in someone's day
you know this is like the founding
philosophy
of my wife jessica jackley who is the
best person i know
but she just says the same thing over
and over again be kind be kind be kind
that's it
that's it just be kind all you got to do
everything else will work itself out i
would just add one thing
and i would add the word rewind you're
showing how old you are man
you know how to find us we're on socials
at reza aslan
at rayne wilson the show is on twitter
at metamilkpodcast it's on instagram at
metaphysical milkshake
and tell us what would you do with that
trolley or better yet
give us your best trolley problem and
remember to follow rate and review
metaphysical milkshake on apple podcasts
please write the little review just take
take a few seconds if you like the show
it helps us a great deal
thank you to our guest the fantastic
mike shore
thank you see you all next time thank
you
[Music]
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan
gulris lucina and daryush puzuela no
thaft of soul pancake
hashem himself is the head of production
metaphysical milkshake is produced by
amy s choi
and rebecca lehrer of the mashup
americans associate producers are
jocelyn gonzalez
lindsey crowell sarah pellegrini mary
phillips sandy and shelby sandlin
original music by jeff tang and scott
[Music]
tang
[Music]
so i guess my question for you we really
want to you know metaphysical milkshake
we dive into some some
really uh intense metaphysical concepts
philosophical ideas spiritual ideas
psychological truths etc but
since we started on the office why have
you not given me a single
[ __ ] job on any of your other goddamn
shows yeah well rain uh i think one
reason might be the anger you just
flashed
by asking me that question wow okay all
right
i'm so glad somebody else we were
cousins
we were on a beet farm together